[Music]
Machinery pulls the steel ribbons
through an oven which heats them to a
searing 1832 degrees Fahrenheit the
steel that enters a cooling chamber
followed by another oven the temperature
extremes changed the steels molecular
structure it becomes harder and stronger
the steel rewinds and then unwinds
between grinding stones that hone the
edge into a very sharp gothic arch
profile they're now ready to break the
steel into individual blades a
mechanical punch snaps it and it breaks
cleanly with a skewer holding the blades
in alignment
a technician scrutinizes the edges for
any defects after applying coatings to
prevent rust and add durability they
bake the blades in a special furnace
this binds the coatings to the blades at
another station they transform plastic
pellets into the razor cartridges this
machine melts the pellets and injects
the liquid plastic into molds as
pressure is applied the plastic
solidifies into the shape of razor
cartridges
the cartridges bounced along a circular
feeder the feeder Orient's them front
side up and then funnels them into the
next machine
[Music]
this one resembles an octopus with
numerous tentacles the tentacles are
robots the first one places the
cartridges in a fixture on a revolving
table as the table turns it serves up
the cartridges to the next robots in the
assembly line in quick succession
these robots snap a total of five blades
into the cartridges by now the holes
used to move the blades through the
assembly process have been trimmed off
and it's a perfect fit
they now place back casings in front of
the cartridges and install pieces of
metal on the parts the metal pieces are
sacrificial anodes their sole purpose is
to be sacrificed to corrosive forces to
save the blades after that robots flip
the back casings then transfer them to
the cartridge blades and click them into
place the cartridge blades are now fully
assembled
[Music]